this is the Science of
Stupid
warning the following program contains
toxic levels of
stupidity please do not copy any of the
dangerous stunts you see but feel free
to use the
science yes this is the show that
detects the
science hidden in the
stupid learn as untrained researchers
examine the laws of Science and fail to
understand
them we'll discover what went wrong and
why it shouldn't
have with the help of simple scientific
principles such as impact
Force
momentum and of course
friction challenge science and you open
the door to
stupidity
watch out it's the Science of
Stupid in this episode we'll be
examining the difference between
fear and
phobia between
traction and no
traction and we'll be looking at
stability in
water or the lack of it anyway but first
this
I love cycling it offers so many modes
of exploring physics I've got my road
bike for the commute my mountain bike
for the trails And my trial bike for the
ridiculous this is bike
trials where Riders show off astonishing
Feats of balance over
obstacles or at least try
to the next time someone tells you
something is as easy as riding a bik
bike tell them they don't know what
they're talking about unless of course
they've understood the science we're
talking Center of mass and Newton's
favorite reaction
force first he shifts his weight back by
pulling on the handlebars to help lift
the front
wheel while driving down on the pedal to
generate a large reaction force
launching him into the
air before landing he applies the back
brake to help keep the combined Center
of mass of him and his bike over the
small base of support at his
wheel he then releases the brake to
repeat the
process there you go it's a big reaction
force for the hopping and a carefully
balanced combined Center of mass for the
not falling over good simple physics but
let's see if our young trialists were
paying
attention he wasn't
starting on one wheel gives him a tiny
base of support and when he leans his
Center of mass too far forward gravity
causes him to
Pivot which might have been less painful
if he'd bother to wear a
helmet it's a weird choice of location
but go for it good
start back wheel locked ready for the
big jump lots of downward
force and he's made it
momentarily on Landing he was leaning
too far back which means the center of
mass was once again outside of the base
of
support maybe next time just bring your
swimsuit to the pool like everyone
else here we go good
technique great
balance oh maybe the pool wasn't such a
bad
idea
he hasn't generated enough reaction
force so he lacks the momentum to make
the second
wall look this clearly isn't working why
don't we try going down rather than
up see gravity is your
friend but not checking what you're
landing on is your fault maybe it's not
the jumper it's the bike so let's try a
different
one much
better I think it's time we took a break
from watching the scientifically
challenged and concentrate on one of
science's Heroes Tyler Brad kayaker
extraordinaire he wants to kayak over
this poo Falls in
Washington thousands of cubic feet of
water pass over this fall every second
and drop 186 ft to the pool below
to consider kaying over this you must
either be a few sandwiches short of a
picnic or a world record breaker we
hope oh there he is the new world record
holder for one of the most dangerous
stunts I have ever
seen needless to say even if you do have
186t water feature don't try this at
home or anywhere else falling off a
waterfall is the easy part but as
gravity initially accelerates you down
at 32 ft per second per second it's
surviving that's the tricky
bit our kayaker must go over the falls
at the correct speed to give gravity
just enough time to generate the angular
velocity needed to rotate the kayak
90° this angle minimizes hydrodynamic
drag so he experiences less impact force
and cuts through the
water it's also worth noting that a
kayak's stability is dependent on
keeping the center of mass in line with
the center of buoyancy which is in the
middle of a submerged
volume
otherwise okay science taught let's see
if our team of wannabe record Breakers
have
learned he's practicing the science with
a man-made kind of waterfall but the law
of
gravity is the
same the thin layer of water acting as a
lubricant combined with the Steep angle
allows gravity to do its
thing it's not quite the 32 ft per
second per second of a waterfall
freefall but he's only practicing
on to angular
[Music]
velocity or in this case the lack of
it launching too fast meant he gained
very little angular velocity hitting the
H2O at a terrible angle thereby
maximizing hydro dynamic
drag which is bad as it brought him to
an almost immediate and very painful
stop waterfall check
angular velocity
check stability check
is it's an upside down check but
technically he still got himself into a
stable position it's just a shame his
Center of mass is directly below his
Center of buoyancy as his head is the
thing he uses to
breathe cheering without acknowledging
the person that just saved your life
[Music]
check even if our wner B record Breakers
do get to grips with angular velocity
hydrodynamic drag and stability like
Tyler did 186 ft is just too
dangerous maybe it's better to kayak
somewhere
safer like a
puddle now then can you deduce what
scientific concept this young man is
about to demonstrate by jumping over his
friends
did you work out the science he was
testing that's right it's angular
momentum as our jumper takes off he has
little angular momentum and so would
have landed on his feet but the beam
applies a force to his
head causing him to gain angular
momentum luckily his friends were there
to break his
fall and he was okay in the
end Avid Science of Stupid viewer and
32nd president of the United States
Franklin Roosevelt said the only thing
we have to fear is fear itself well
obviously he never suffered from
Arachnophobia he's trying to get to
just remember how's he doing that they
are as frightened of you as you are of
them apart from that one
obviously Arachnophobia the fear of
spiders is a funny old mix between
practical survival and totally
irrational Behavior fear isn't the enemy
a rational fear
is for example a fear of a big dog
bearing sharp teeth
sensible but fear of a plid small dog
phobia fear of spiders is logical as
some are venomous in fact research
suggests it could be genetic babies were
shown pictures of spiders and their
pupils enlarged even though they may
have never seen one
before it's part of the fight or flight
response where chemicals are released
into the bloodstream increasing in
respiratory rates and blood flow to the
muscles preparing the body to fight
back or in his case
flee of around 43,000 different spiders
in the world less than 30 have ever
killed anyone but it's believed our
innate fear of them may have stemmed
from our cave dwelling ancestors who
might have had more contact with the
more deadly and less itsy bitsy of those
43,000 anyway
lesson
over maybe a nice glass of milk to calm
the
[Music]
nerves because she didn't expect to see
a spider her reaction is
instinctive flight and
screaming hello
spider now he knows exactly what he's
doing he's teasing this jumping
[Music]
spider and is not called a jumping
spider for
nothing this species can suddenly
increase blood pressure in its legs so
that they instantly extend propelling it
forwards up to several times its body
length which also causes a sudden rush
of blood in our spider
botherer one particularly clean
researcher has discovered a spider in
his bath and obviously he doesn't have a
phobia as he's happy to poke
it not so happy
anymore when his eight-legged friend
jumps in our bther gets a heavy dose of
fight or flight
chemicals less relaxing than a bubble
bath but remember fear can be sensible
some spiders carry enough toxins to kill
an
adult others not so
much her fear causes her body to bypass
her rational brain to react to the
danger and Escape before she even
realizes it isn't a real
[Music]
spider but running on the spot probably
not the best flight
reaction I'm so glad we K that as our
way rallying is the ultimate Grassroots
racing sport it takes road legal cars
and turns them into racing
machines
and
sometimes into spare
parts you see while some rally events
cater for your jacked up Pro cars others
specialize in vehicles that well look a
bit more like your granddad's old bucket
to win any rally it helps to stay on the
track and professional rally cars are
packed with modifications to help them
navigate and survive the toughest of
races Pro rally cars have specially
designed tires with grippier tread
patterns and they're made from a softer
rubber compound that conforms to a range
of
surfaces to maximize
traction many Pros also use four-wheel
drive Distributing torque which improves
traction to Aid cornering and reducing
the risk of an unwanted under steer or
over
steer shame that one was a two wheel
drive in the professional realm those
enhancements are very much standard and
expertly engineered to perfection
in the amateur
world it's more about crossing your
[Music]
fingers the lack of traction in this old
car's hard skinny tires causes it to
over steer and when the driver tries to
correct this he makes it
worse which is why these purus fans have
decided to turn on him I'd run if I were
you and that's why many rally drivers
favor the four-wheel
drive of which that is
not front-wheel drives are more prone to
under steer as the front wheels can lose
traction on the
corner luckily it won't be too expensive
to
[Music]
replace H loose grav
surface that should help us drift into a
ditch
high- performance rally cars can hug a
corner at high speed this little
hatchback prefers to over steer and
embrace the
ditch but upgrade that runaround with
all the right bits in the trophy is in
the
bag he kept the steering wheel
[Music]
right
surfing exhilarating stuff but sadly we
don't all live near the beach and
surfing without surf just isn't the same
is
it or is
[Music]
it it's not nevertheless it turns out
that surfing onun grass is a thing not a
particularly safe or advisable thing but
a thing nonetheless while there are less
sharks the stopping bit can really bite
thanks to the dead-eyed fun killer we
call
friction an initial input of forward
velocity like a running start will help
overcome the static friction with the
grass and then gravity can provide
additional
momentum the lower the coefficient of
kinetic friction between the grass and
the board the more effective gravity
will be as he Glides over the
grass sitting or lying is easier than
standing as up right Surfers have a
higher Center of mass which is trickier
to keep over their base of
support basically it's pretty much the
same as water surfing just a lot less
salty and a lot more hery okay first up
we need to overcome static friction a
little runup will do but even better if
we catch ourselves a good wave I mean
hell like this
one
but without the gigantic
Bush gravity caused this Rider to pick
up velocity very quickly and his
momentum meant he couldn't stop in time
to avoid the
Shrubbery maybe next time try somewhere
with less shrubs and more
space that's better hang on that's
cheating yeah serves you
[Music]
right he appears to hit a rough patch
and the increased kinetic friction slows
the board making it very hard to keep
his Center of mass over his base of
support so what if we lower that Center
of mass by lying
down well he didn't fall over but since
the wet weather decreased the friction
between him and his board when the board
stopped sliding his momentum kept him
going
I made exactly the same mistake this
morning get the friction
right and it's amazing what momentum can
do on
grass sand that's a whole other
science if I asked you to stop what
you're doing get up off the couch and do
the splits you would naturally ask me to
be more
specific do I mean a passive split where
you use the weight of your body no
muscle work just gravity okay I think we
get the point or the split sleep which
you perform in the air less annoying but
probably more
tiring I think let's look at the leapy
ones now the Pinnacle of the leaping
splits is obviously the grand jate
leaping gracefully into the air like a
bird in flight and Landing with the
lightest of touches of course to master
it you need to understand the science
that's Vertical Velocity angular
momentum and our old chum base of
support first she generates enough
Vertical Velocity at takeoff for
sufficient air time to fully extend her
legs meanwhile generating plenty of
angular momentum to bring both legs 90°
to the upper body
as she lands she uses the muscles and
joints in her legs like shock
absorbers bending to reduce the impact
Force while ensuring her Center of mass
comes over her base of support for
stability and don't forget the
coefficient of friction between the
dancer's feet and the ground in other
words don't
[Music]
slip well someone wasn't paying
attention
generating too much angular momentum is
practically a guarantee of a center of
mass outside of base of support style
Landing but while you can reduce the
impact force with your legs your face is
less
effective maybe try it without so much
spin maybe try it without smashing into
the
floor same
problem yep that's way too much angular
momentum and that is definitely not
Landing over your
[Music]
base okay maybe the wood's too slippery
how about a different wood
altogether nice angular
momentum room for
improvement her Grandes were good but
her spatial awareness needs a bit of
work maybe we should just forget about
all the jumping and instead allow
gravity to ease us into our splits
well they don't call them splits for
nothing your leaping days are over my
friend and that's it we've done all we
can to help the scientifically
challenged please do not attempt any of
the dangerous stunts you have just seen
as Benjamin Franklin is alleged to have
said we're all born ignorant but one
must work hard to remain stupid and
guess what these guys have worked really
[Music]
[Applause]
hard
[Music]
it